Oh today I'm gonna tell you about some
work I've been doing an OP to her on
what I call finding needles in a growing
haystack and how we do intelligent
reporting at scale on time series so I
work at op divert and we have been
around for about 30 years so it's a
local company here at MCM but we also
have offices in Sydney in Chicago and
Shanghai and we're continue to expand as
we go into new markets and look at where
the opportunities are and what we do is
something called market making and I
always get a lot of people don't really
understand what this is but I thought
I'd take a minute to explain what
exactly this is so a market maker or
liquidity provider shows a bid and an
offer in an order book so on the see if
this works well I'll just say so on the
right side here I have an order book so
you have some buyers you have some
sellers they have prices they're willing
to do traits for and there's different
amounts they're willing to try to buy or
sell so what we do is we always offer
both a bit and an offer price and what
we try to do is we try to narrow this
gap between the highest price that
buyers are willing to to buy for and the
lowest price that sellers are willing to
sell for in order to help people make
trades because if we're not there then
people have to actually pay a lot more
to buy than they want or so for a lot
lower price than what they really want
to so we don't try to bet that the
market goes up or down instead we simply
try to provide a price and help people
actually make these transactions and
every time this transaction happens we
make this price between the bid and ask
the spread so that's what we do and back
in the days this involved sending in a
giant pit full of people trying to yell
the loudest of your voice to to get
people to hear your price but nowadays
this is really an IT job so we have
co-located servers around the world and
working as a trader means staring at six
gigantic computer screens full of
information trying to make decisions
so we collect a lot of data so one of
the markets we are active in is your ex
in Frankfurt and on a single day last
year we reported 180 gigabytes of
network traffic we made 100 gigabytes of
log files and in just a single hour at
the end of the day there were 20,000
changes on a stock the Deutsche Bank on
the futures there's twice as much over
40,000 and if you look at the options
which is what we trade most actively
there were more than two point three
million changes so we generate tons of
data across the day because we're
trading on multiple markets around the
world and the problem like many of you
face is that this data is growing over
time so in this chart I have the number
of orders we're sending per day and a
measure of how fast the exchange is in
orange so you can see is that as time
goes on the exchanges are getting faster
and faster and as a result we're doing
more and more transactions with the
exchange but the problem is as a market
maker we need to try to make sure our
prices are always up-to-date and then
we're making the trace you want so we
need to constantly try to monitor are we
doing a good job or not so I'm on the
data team adoptive er and what we do is
we handle this whole pipeline so we
collect data in the collocation we move
it to the 2f strand for our data
warehousing and then we do a lot of work
trying to select and enrich the data and
then in the end serve analysis or
reports to people throughout the company
so one of the key problems we often face
is trying to basically find needles in
the haystack so this I'm showing here is
a specific case in which we were making
changes that we knew about that we hoped
would make our trading better so in this
case better means a lower number on this
graph and you can see as time goes on
that there are a couple periods where
there's a drop so that's good and we
were trying to do this but the problem
is we trade a lot of things and we don't
have enough people really to always try
to figure out to be actively looking at
these things of finding when unexpected
things happen and you might think okay
well I know the most important things I
care about so I can track that but the
problem is that
as you dig into the data deeper and
deeper they are exponentially growing
number numbers of time series that you
might want to take a look at so these
are real numbers here going over I think
I picked like seven different factors so
in the end we have something like a
hundred thousand time series that we
potentially want to track every single
day so what we really need is some smart
automated way to look for interesting
results and in this talk today I'm gonna
try to show you two different sites of
how we solve this problem so on the one
hand we need to do smart analytical work
so I'm going to try to convince you of a
particular analytical philosophy and
show you some statistical algorithms
that we use for solving this problem but
we'll have been find missing some of
these talks is that it's not only having
some awesome model that you're using to
look at your data there's also a lot of
technical work to make it really work in
production because again this is stuff
that we have happening live every single
day and we need this information so I'm
gonna show you a little about some of
the software architectural decisions we
made in implementing our analysis as
well as the operational procedures we
use for making sure this is running and
we can keep track of our results and
while I'm not gonna actually show you
much real Python code on my slides today
we are our team at least we're basically
building all the software in Python
custom software built on top of these
community projects that's you hear about
at PI data here today as well as
published research so for the first part
let's take a look I'm gonna try to
convince you that we can solve this
analytical problem by doing automated
discovery with iterative basing
algorithms so as Vincent mentioned I
used to be a research scientist and
actually I never use any Bayesian
statistics in my scientific research but
when I came to working in the real real
world at a financial company what I
found very quickly is that the the
benefits of basing statistics really
start to win out
so as spouse Ari so the what challenges
do we face in trying to do this analysis
well I think there's three different
main categories so one is that we want
our analysis to be robust
so although we start with a large amount
of data as we dig deeper and deeper
into our analysis we're gonna very
quickly run into limits where we don't
have so much data and ideally we'd like
to have the same tools that we can apply
to both these large data scales as well
as small data on the other hand we want
to stay sensitive so we have a lot of
different reports so you want to look at
I told you we have up to a hundred
thousand week things we're trying to
look at in this case and I don't want to
be generating lots of false positives so
that people stop paying attention to the
things I'm trying to find and finally we
need to make sure we maintain
performance so again this data is
streaming in every day and so we want to
make sure that all the analysis we do we
can do on manageable chunks of data we
don't want to have to try to load up
lots of historical data every time we
want to generate a report so I think
basically statistics are real key to
trying to solve this problem and at the
core as core basically statistics can be
described by this question what can I
say about my model given my expectations
and what I see now so amazing in terms
this part what I see now is our data
that we are collecting and we have
before we see the data we have some
expectations that's called the prior and
then the combination of those two things
and our model then lets us have
something we can say a posterior so math
terms is expressed as this simple
equation here so our posterior is equal
to our likelihood times our prior and if
you're used to frequentist statistics
it's a bit of a change in perspective so
from the frequentist side of things the
parameters of your model are fixed and
you have some data which you think is a
random sample of overall population and
what you're trying to do is try to see
if your two populations are the same or
not so there's a very funny comic from
xkcd something I viewed very regularly
where they asked did the Sun just
explode so they have a detector which
lies to you one on the 36 times and you
get a measurement which says yes so one
out of 36 is less this one observation
is less than the one out of 36 so the by
a simple p-value
test you end up saying yes the Sun
exploded but the Bayesian says no I
don't think so and the reason why is
that as a Bayesian your data is fixed
and instead what you're trying to say is
what is the range of possible values
that my parameters could have and as you
get more data you can make more more
clear statements about your parameters
of your model so what makes this key to
solving this problem of doing analysis
on growing large data sets is that we
can do this in an iterative way so again
we start with our prior belief we
collect some data we can then compute
how likely that data is given our prior
and that lets us update our posterior
but we can then use that posterior as
our new prior for the next round of data
we get so let's look at an example of
something real that we do
so one thing we care a lot about are the
is the success rate of our orders so if
we're sending orders into to the
exchange are we actually making the Tres
you want you can think also I heard a
lot about conversion rates earlier for
the basing an a/b testing it's a very
similar sort of thing so we start with a
prior in this case that we have some
particular success rate so we expressed
as a fraction between 0 and 1 that
naturally Falls as a beta distribution
if you think it was basing but we have
two choices here so we could start with
an uninformative prior which means that
we think we don't really know anything
about what that rate might be but on the
other hand we could also have some
stronger belief so for example we could
take like a historical average and use
that as our input so I have a graph here
showing some example probability
distributions so on the x-axis is the
success rate and on the y-axis is our
probability or likelihood in this case
so for the uninformative prior there's
all ranges of success rates have some
considerable probability of being real
but in dark blue I have the historical
average one so you can see that's much
more
around some fixed value but now what
happens is that we collect some data
which in this case our successes or
failures so binary outcome and we can
now compute a likelihood in this case
it's a Bernoulli distribution because we
have Biscay coin flips and from that we
can update our posterior so I've shown
on the graph here that these are all
beta distributions in this case and this
this is what we believe the success rate
is now that we've seen data so the case
in light gray is what you would do if
you had this uninformative prior where
beforehand we didn't know anything so
you see now it's clustering around the
real value which I think in this case
was something like 40% but I don't where
when the bread put in now but on the
other hand if we started with this
historical average which is the dark
blue then you see the light blue curve
is the posterior again in this case so
it shifted a bit to the right because
the value is not quite the same as it
was before but we are more confident in
the result because we started off
beforehand thinking it was somewhere
close to that so one of the key things
shown here is that this updating of a
posterior because we have both the beta
distribution in the beginning and in the
end has a very simple mathematical
equation so we're just keeping track of
some sums of how many times we fail how
many times we succeed and this is an
example of what's called a conjugate
prior so these are analytical equations
for simple models and they're really
nice because they're an equation they're
very fast you don't need to do any
optimization we don't need to try
changing all the parameters but it's
still useful even though it's a simple
model so the graph here is some actual
data from our from that I'm monitoring
so I'm doing this sort of using a
historical prior and then checking the
data we get every day and you can see we
can now track how this success rate is
evolving in time and because we're doing
this from a basically perspective we
also have very clear ideas of
uncertainty in our data so the shading
here represents a 95% credible interval
so we think with 95% probability that
the real success rate is somewhere in
that range
so if we have very little data then this
might get much larger and if we have a
lot of data we'll get more and more
specific about what we think that the
success rate is but we can also do more
advanced things so I recently started to
learn about Bayesian nonparametric
methods and I've now become a very huge
fan of them I'm trying to figure out all
the ways I can apply them to my data so
these are tools for scaling model
complexity as our data size grows so if
we have little data then we just use a
simple model we don't want to have too
many parameters describing our small
dataset but if we have lots of data then
we can incorporate the complexity we see
in our data and use that in our model
and there are two two classes of models
are used for this purpose so the first
is a dershlit process so this lets you
model arbitrarily complex distributions
and the other are Gaussian processes
which let you model arbitrarily complex
relationships between variables or in
other words functions so as an example
of how I'm using this one thing I've
done with this is to do sort of a
regular iced quantile estimation so if
you use the d'Orsay process it also
works as a conjugate prior so you can
start off with something like a
parametric distribution like a normal
distribution or a log normal and in this
case the model says that your data are
just some discrete samples from this
distribution and then the posterior is
an updated form of the distribution just
adding in point samples so if you have
lots and lots of data then what happens
is that you essentially just use your
empirical distribution but if you have
very little data then this prior you put
in serves as a sort of regularization
making the distribution more smooth and
also potentially providing some bias but
again there are nice analytical
solutions so you're not going to be able
to really read this equation probably
but this comes from 1973 paper and in
the end you can just compute for any
particular quantile of your data some
likelihood of it being a particular
value so we can use this now to get
actual uncertainty estimates and again
to provide some smoothing if we don't
have very much data for a particular
case so to show you that this
works in practice here again are some
charts showing some measurements over
time for different quantiles showing an
increase in colors of blue and again you
can see that the more extreme quantiles
or force as you might expect a little
bit more noisy and now we can really
clearly see that there's a much larger
range of data that could be a larger
range of quantiles that could be
explained by this data but again one of
the important things I want to show is
that we can also try to figure out what
events are actually interesting in our
data so to do this I'm also using a base
game model in this case I'm doing an
online linear regression to model
continuously changing trend and noise in
our data and outliers are modeled as
having an unusually high variance term
and again because we're doing a
basically model we have probability
distributions for all the parameters in
the model so essentially it's like a
normal linear regression the only
difference is that the the variance term
so this first equation here the Y is a
normal distribution with some
coefficients based on your data and you
have this Sigma squared term it's now
divided by a weighting term so outliers
essentially are seen as having very
small weight in this regression that
you're doing over time and we can model
how the probability distribution of
points being outliers so we found this
works quite well in practice for our
data so I have a case here which is
actually just showing that the trend of
detection parts but again if you look at
this case I showed earlier what we're
doing is optimization over time I now
have in red the the prediction of this
online linear regression and again it's
looking automatically to say certain
points or outliers or not and also
detecting a trend so we use this for
labeling our data as being increasing or
decreasing or outliers and I'll show you
later some examples of how it actually
works in detecting these cases so to
recap the analysis part of things I try
to argue free to you that Bayesian
statistics are useful because they have
good scaling properties so we can go
from small data sets to large data sets
with the same techniques they give us a
really clear
picture of how uncertain we are about
our statements and we can do it in this
sort of iterative way where we we
process smaller chunks of data at a time
wherever possible we try to use
conjugate priors because even though
there's simple models they're fast so we
can do them for lots of different cases
and I showed you a couple examples how
we use this to calculate metrics and
infer outliers and trends in our data
but again this analysis can be nice on
paper but actually putting it into
production is a lot of work so for the
second part I'm going to tell you about
how we actually scale this analysis to
work in our production environments so
again we face some different challenges
so one of the first ones is that we're
collecting a lot of data every single
day and we have a lot of historical data
so we need to make sure that we don't
overload our database that we don't run
out of memory on the server we're
running this on we also potentially have
a very large workload so we have a lot
of different jobs we want to run and if
we're not careful that might be too slow
because again we need to get the results
as soon as possible and we definitely
can't have them taking more than a day
and finally we want to make sure that
our our analysis is stable so we want to
check every day are we having errors
happening as our performance getting
better getting worse so for the first
part might tell you about the software
architecture we use to solve these
problems and then I'll show you some of
the operational things we do to make
sure our systems run well so I'm gonna
build up the parts of the architecture
in a couple pieces so first let's look
at how we get the data so we tend to do
at least in our team is that we abstract
our databases with rest api's and these
are as pipe usually flask application is
serving data this lets us cache queries
that we're getting so if we run the same
query multiple times we already have the
data downloaded and in the program I do
for this analysis reporting
we then cache larger chunks of data so
typically for the data for an entire day
for some environment trading environment
or trading market and then each report
is for some subset of this data so what
we can do is then with this cache data
we can use simple filtering aggregation
transformation on the data we've already
down
and then convert that into a smaller
pandas dataframe that we want to do our
work on so this way we're we're caching
the data at multiple spots so database
system caching the REST API desc caching
and then our actual script grabs a large
chunk of data so we don't need to go for
every single one of these tens of
thousands of reports doing additional
database queries the second part is that
we do this iterative analysis to reduce
the workload so the way I actually do
things in practice is that I have a
MongoDB which has some description of
our state so for every analysis what I
do is I grab the previous state so the
report from the previous day or the last
time it was available I have this new
chunk of data and then the analysis code
takes States data and generates a new
state which I can put back into MongoDB
so I'm only ever having to work with a
single piece of single day of data at a
time and I don't have to do historical
queries so this puts a little constraint
on what sort of analysis I can do
because usually I still want to have
some some influence from the past but I
need to write Mike my analysis
algorithms so they can at least operate
only on a single chunk of data at a time
and all of these components we've made
quite generic so we can easily write new
reports so like in this case I'm running
I had analysis on some performance
measure of how well we're able to match
up our data and I can just write a
little adapter because I didn't actually
have the column in quite the right
format I wanted so I can write a simple
little line that will map one pandas
series to the new one I need and then I
have several prepackaged analyses I've
used for multiple things so for example
the success rate analysis I showed you
earlier I can now just write that I want
to do this on a particular column of my
data so it's very easy for me to add new
reports and it automatically figures out
how to do everything else so in the end
these reports get stored as JSON
documents among go and one thing that we
found quite useful is that we can
actually type these things with a
library called marshmallow which is nice
cuz you can then nest
documents you can extend them and in
this case all I do is I put some
information about what what how I
selected the data for the reports
whether or not I consider to be having
an alert and then the actual numbers I
want to report and if I need to keep
some state about what I'm doing I have
the internal state there and these
marshmallow documents are really easy to
write you just write basically a new
class which derives from schema and then
you say it's like writing a sequel
alchemy model if you're familiar with
that so you should write your fields and
then you write some typed way and so
it'll take care of dealing with all the
the non JSON encode abow things in your
Python structure now we still have a lot
of jobs we're going to run so we are
building an in-house cluster a top 2
verb and what we're running is Apache
mesos so if you're not familiar this is
a resource management tool which
abstracts away resources at using unix c
groups and so you have three notes that
are masters that take care of hen
figuring out where your tasks should go
and run and then the slave nose run the
task and report back so if your jobs
fail it'll automatically take care of
restarting them and we're still in the
process of building it but we've already
got quite a quite a large chunk of
resources so this is the most recent one
I grabbed so we have now around 800
course on our cluster and 100 sorry
520 gigabytes of memory and 20 terabytes
of local disk plus additional storage on
the network to manage our jobs then we
use another framework from Apache Aurora
so Aurora is a framework from Bezos so
he takes care of telling mesas what to
do and we found Aurora was quite nice
because we can do both cron jobs and
also one-time ad hoc jobs so you write a
little python script that tells tells us
what commands to run and then it takes
care of putting it on to may system
running it regularly so then what we do
to actually parallelize fee this runs is
we start with a lot of reports we're
gonna run and I split the mess on
high-level aggregation so in practice
the way I make these report filters is I
have a series of ways in which people
want to drill down into the data so I
take the top level filters from
data so in this case it's our trading
environments in a market and that
becomes a job for Aurora or a mazes task
and then within that I do paralyzation
with multi processing and Python using
job Lib so I download the data once for
this high level filter so that's this
first level of layer of caching and then
for each report filter you grab the data
you need and you send the report filter
the smaller chunk of data to individual
core for job Lib for processing and then
they all send the data back to MongoDB
so this works quite well and again
there's a lot of jobs so one of the
problems we found in practices you have
to figure out did everything work ok is
how is our high performance going so we
have a lot of custom tools in opt we
built for monitoring production jobs so
one thing we have is an API which lets
you pump basically any performance
metric you want to a time series
database on the backend and we're
running gree fauna as a way of
visualizing this data so for example we
have this tool built by one of the
operational people on our team would
look at how the cluster is being used
over time so this is a earlier case in
which we are running it and you can see
in the middle of the graphs is when my
my reporting jobs kick off so there's a
big spike in the CPU CPU usage and the
number here is an average so it's
actually higher during the runs so I
think I hit something like 200 course
right now or 400 for some my jobs and
there's also a spike in the RAM and the
disk usage of course - but it quickly
goes back over time so my code is
working fine I'm not actually an
operational person so it's always good
to check to check these things we also
have tools for monitoring did our jobs
actually what's happening with all for
our work so we have a we'll call health
system where we can basically pump a
state visit running is a failing is
there something wrong going on Status
Messages and there's a web api on the
backend which then you can then go look
and see what's going on with all my
stuff so I can very quickly go go to the
website and at the time I took the
screenshot I see oh one of my reports is
currently in the middle of running
and again we monitor our log files for
errors that happen so if there's
something in this thousands of jobs are
happening we can detect errors and and
respond to them and we can track the
performance of these jobs over time so
to recap the technical side of things
from a software architecture point of
view we use multiple levels of Cashin to
try to reduce our impact on our data
database back-end we implement these
analyses in an iterative way so that we
don't need to actually look so far back
in the past and we use these JSON
schemas in [ __ ] to allow us to evolve
how our our models and data structures
look over time then we paralyze the data
on our in-house cluster in multiple
multiple levels of parallelization and
we also monetary these using lots of
different production tools to make sure
that things were running the way we
expect so in the end when we get out of
this is a tool we use called the data
dashboard which again is a flask REST
API serving these pre-calculated reports
from MongoDB and then it's an internal
website built using reacts the
JavaScript frameworks react Redux and hi
charts and just show you a couple of
graphs from this these are again real
real cases from the analysis so on the
left is a case for this success rate
analysis on the right is a case for
tracking a quantile of the data and so
you can see the the red highlighted
points are outliers that the program
detected which also happened in this
case to be down trends so it's a down
arrow with a red highlight and again
they're shading because I have actual
measures of how uncertain I am about
these numbers so people which I find in
practice is quite important because
otherwise a lot of times people care a
lot about these numbers and they might
get overly excited about small bumps on
this curve so we're automatically
detecting these trends and outliers and
revealing them to users we're clearly
indicating the uncertainty and this is
when we run live in production every day
with data coming in so I have a slide
here with all the different components
are using for different parts of our
technology stack
don't know how am i doing on time okay
so yeah I mentioned quite a bit this but
I'm just going to emphasize some of the
stuff so on the cluster side we're using
the Apache framework mezzos and Aurora
and python chocolate which I love for
managing multi processing I also learned
earlier about this more about async IO
and Python so I think I'm gonna go back
and try to use this with some of my
things now for the database side of
things we're using marshmallow for
defining our schemas MongoDB for storing
these documents and we do Oliver our
REST API stuff using the request package
and flash servers and you WSGI for
making our servers of course we use all
the sci-fi stack soap and s and numpy
sci-fi also we use a lot of you find
that arrow is really nice for us because
we work a lot with this operational data
and things different time zones so it's
a library which lets you converts time
date times easily to different formats
in a really expressive way another thing
we've also started using recently is
this library pi dash which lets you
write some functional programming type
styles with your data in Python for the
analysis side of things right now most
of the work is basically just actually
taking equations or algorithms from
papers and writing them in scifi numpy
Theano in some cases I play a little bit
with actual Monte Carlo algorithms as
well pi abc3 which maybe you're familiar
with but right now for this sort of
thing in practice it's not really fast
enough to run for these sort of large
jobs I find so it's nice for doing some
exploratory things but I'm not using so
much for our live data and then Y on our
desk or side we're using the react
framework with Redux and hi charts for
visualization
so with that I'll sighs that we're
always hiring so if you're thinking
you're interested these sort data
problems and working with yeah kind of
different data problems in some other
places we're hiring researchers data
scientists data engineers DevOps and
traders as well so thank you guys for
listening and I'll be happy to take any
questions
[Applause]